o olá a todos meu nome é muito tenho 21
anos e sou com muitos consideram um
artista de música mas na minha opinião e
só um bocadinho menos do que isso é só
um artista porque sinto que estou cá
para espalhar uma mensagem para
transmitir uma visão seja em que
vertente artística forno
e eu comecei a cantar por volta dos 15
anos e a partir daí nunca mais para os
canto escrevo produz e toca alguns
instrumentos
eu sempre fui muito curioso ligada à
natureza e fascinado na sensações que
além de transmitir após alguns anos de
pesquisa e de algumas experiências em
seres humanos e desenvolveu o primeiro
álbum dar de vida
nós estamos estamos mais algumas coisas
sobre mim da melhor maneira que eu sei
este tema chama-se cuba davi
é porque quis fazer a diferença tão
fácil dói-me a que pensa cantar comigo
merece ser ouvido e eu vivo 8/80
trabalho levantar eu tava cheio de
suscitar não sei o conta convidar eu
estou bem só não governar eu sou rei não
vou apagar algo só para acertar no alvo
se tem coração parou colorir arrancá-lo
do meu eu já não sei nem quero que quero
família paz tranquilidade e eu vivo tipo
o futuro vermelho pa a qualidade e parou
de fa ii
e ele me deu minha curta jornada eu
comecei a perceber kart podia ser muito
mais que uma expressão ela podia
funcionar como uma arma mais poderosa
que os seres humanos possuem eu vou ter
este ponto mas deixa-me já dar alguns
exemplos olha 1978 jamaica atravessava
uma guerra civil política entre os dois
partidos principais do país cima falar
de uma guerra em algumas vidas foram
perdidas e tinha que ter muito cuidado
ao atravessar a rua para não ser
alvejado
é mas no dia vinte e dois de abril desse
mesmo ano realização conserto com o
intuito de juntar o povo unidos nação um
só esse pode ser teve o nome do banho
love country e perde o final da atuação
bob marley chamou ao palco os dois
líderes políticos para o aperto de mão
que simbolizaria o fim dessa guerra
incrível mas vamos continuar a1985 45
vozes unidas por um símbolo que ficaria
marcado na história we are the world
este single contou com as vozes dos
lendários michael jackson tina turner
stevie wonder e tantos outros giram mais
de 7 milhões de cópias vendidas angariou
mais de 60 milhões de dólar e tudo isto
distribuído por 21 países africanos para
combater a fome ea pobreza extrema
dívidas nessas nações
é sim mas vou dar um exemplo mais
próximo todos nós e já se 25 de abril e
impossível dizer esta frase sentir um
orgulho diga aquela que para muitos foi
a mais bela das revoluções enquadrado
tente pintada em tons de vermelho não do
sangue mas de escravos determinavam as
armas dos militares e
é e como se isso não bastasse a maneira
que a melhor forma que o movimento das
forças armadas encontrou para orientar
toda esta resolução via rádio via arte
duas músicas foram escolhidas para esta
noite
o primeiro para marcar o início de todo
o processo um tema de paulo de carvalho
e depois do adeus e posteriormente
poucas horas mais tarde foi transmitido
o tema grândola vila morena de zeca
afonso para avisar as tropas poderiam
avançar e tudo isto são só alguns
distantes exemplos encarte falou mais
alto e se vocês me permitem agora é
minha vez né
o sistema chama-se luna
e por cada vez que o fogo arder até
queimar por cada vez que o vento sopra
telva.es tilt uso para me inspirar tu és
o reflexo do que um caso não é tudo que
se quer se concepções sofrer essa é a
única certeza que eu quero te estrelas
está sempre olhar pede por favor vou te
ajudar
bom então é
ou então liga para o duas e agora não
importa sim saber se amas os leais os
que tornam lindas em quantos reais
entregam a tua arte e fazem te queimar
eu não quero voltar ter sensação de te
perder não penses em acomodar de que eu
também sorri gente sempre quis o meu
lugar e muito mais que um novo tempo
continuar a falar e por tiros e
bom então fez comigo eu sou eu
um vídeo no ar
e eu queria esta obra com intuito de
imortalizar o momento em que estava a
escrever
eu quero um momento de paz e paz é uma
sensação que eu não senti muito nesta
altura
sim eu travava uma guerra interior
é e essas para mim são as mais difíceis
de vencer as até nestas situações a arte
fala mais alto e falou esta arma
poderosa tanto nos assento aos pés na
terra como os transporta para outro
universo esclarecer as nossas dúvidas e
faz no estudo cristina
e isso é muito mais que uma mera opinião
eu não sei se estão familiarizados com a
arteterapia como o nome indica uma
terapia com base na arte com base em
piorou
os instrumentos o processo criativo de
criar arte para melhorar o nosso bem
estar físico mental e emocional
é eu sei que vocês devem estar a pensar
bem eu não tenho talento eu não tenho os
meios não tenho tempo nem tenho a
criatividade mas eu garanto nada disto é
necessário para iniciar a terapia óbvio
que vocês precisam do tempo mas todos a
falar de um método eficaz que envolve
reflexão e processamento de emoções é
para todos e eu sinto responde dar um
sentido foi isso que vocês realmente
procuro amigão é que afinal arte está
desligada no nosso dia a dia seja noite
fiz uma trabalhamos ou na série que
acompanhamos ou até na natureza que nos
rodeia
é isso nós não existíssemos ela nunca
seria interpretada a criação só funciona
com a interpretação nem que seja do
próprio criador
o artista nossa dna nossa herança e eu
vou apertar mais um pouco da minha
convosco pode ser
em ok e sistema chama-se respeitar
e aí
eu vou fica mais à espera que tu vá eu
fiz perceber
a respeitar isso agora que penso nele
expostas desativar de um precipício não
tu não quiseste ouvir o meu ave não
queria dizer mas eu bem diz eu ponho de
disse em deus não quer mas ela pois é
mas no carro agora a minha pensar que eu
não mas eu anota tudinho nunca dou um
toque pus a situações assim mesmo ficam
tão mais de ó ela sabe que eu gosto dela
que eu aposto não deu o melhor carro e
afasta dela o pior mas o pior é que só
faz mesmo pela diversão está se agregar
para os seus olhos então bom fica mais
espero que tu vá
eu fiz percy fred de respeitar isso é
uma vida eu já consegui perceber que às
vezes ela não faz por ter influenciado a
ser uma pergunta e resposta ainda está
para aparecer faz isto porque mas não é
para aparecer porque cargas nas bases e
fases de todas as partes um são pretexto
para jantas evans se não houver noite
acaba no peixinho eu fico paris em
voltar quando de cargas por cara
disparos das tuas amigas animadas na
estrada todas sozinho juro pra tua vida
e aí
e os momentos em que eu não concordava
com o podia nem nem com o que eu ia em
dois disso é assim é normal mas pessoas
a exigirem respeito quando não tinham
para com os outros muito menos por com
elas próprias
ah e tu criaste obra eu queria voltar
reflexão eu queria e quero que haja
consciência a música também é para isto
não é arte também é para isto e voltando
ao início da minha toca é a arma mais
poderosa que nós temos tão poderosa que
muitas vezes transcender um próprio
artista
se você já pensaram que isso uso
criadores por trás das grandes obras é
que a tantas personalidades conhecidas
mas há tantas outras que virão para
sempre nas sombras das suas criações
e quem projeta uma pirâmide quem
desenhou o padre domingo que chora ou
que escreveu o nosso próprio hino
nacional
um sub som são obras que representam
culturas são vozes de nações que os
criadores foram os bancos e com o tempo
a verdade é que não importa não importa
quem projetou no importa quem desenhou
quem escreveu porque as suas obras vivem
elas são imortais e esse é o derradeiro
objetivo de um artista passar a mensagem
de geração para geração compreendo eu
poder
e com uma arma que já vale a viagem
temporalmente átomos milhões de pessoas
ao mesmo tempo atingir um salva
e os cuidado porque estiver pronto para
transmitir essa mensagem para disparar
tem que ter a plena noção que a partir
do momento em que primo gatilho esta
ganha vida ela de escolas de volta de
disparar superam
e nos vimos e saudade desta toque nós
vimos feitos falarem mais alto
intervenientes sejas a humilhações ou
inspirar mudança ou ajudar-nos a vencer
as nossas próprias guerras
é o tema de hoje é perspective esta é a
minha make art not war muito obrigado
e aí